we're going to go back to buffalo again
this morning where the suspect in the
killing of 10 people at a grocery store
is back in court this morning members of
the nfl's buffalo bills visited the
scene of the shooting yesterday the
players and the coaches they prayed they
served lunches and they handed out
groceries to people in the neighborhood
who really need this to rika duncan is
in buffalo with more on the story tarika
i bet many people were glad to see them
yesterday good morning to you
good morning to you gail they absolutely
were it was exciting to see those
professional athletes
in east buffalo these are people who
admire them of course but more
importantly it was about acknowledging
the depravity of what happened and
paying their respects
this is
the buffalo bills touched down in east
buffalo wednesday to the surprise of the
community their pain put on pause even
if only for a moment to be out here and
to see people smiling and laughing again
and
that warms my heart
in a show of solidarity the team handed
out groceries and served meals to
residents now left without a grocery
store after saturday's deadly shooting
at top supermarket
tops is giving free bus rides to its
store a little over three miles away a
temporary fix for a long routed economic
divide i grew up here there used to be
a house here a furniture store there was
a barber shop a fish market but that
divide wasn't always the case says 67
year old ladina clyburn what changed
what changed
it's hard for me to answer that question
some of the business
didn't come back after there was some
riots and protests some of them didn't
come back the tearing up of the 33.
[Applause]
route 33 split the city into east and
west and resulted in even more
businesses losing money not to mention
the bills moved away from this part of
town to the suburbs
the problems on the east side had been
mounting for decades the majority of
people who live here are black it's why
the alleged gunman targeted this
community but it's also why jeremy hoyle
brought his wife and three-year-old
daughter to the memorial why did you
come down here my family and i we want
to be allies
i think it's important to show our
daughter
that and that's why we're here
i'm set for our community and i'm upset
for our city
and officials are also offering free
mental health counseling as well as
compensation for funeral costs and just
to set the scene that you're seeing
behind me in front of court we've seen a
number of officials sheriff's deputies
bomb squad um and tactical units getting
ready for the court appearance of that
accused gunman nate
salute to the buffalo bills it doesn't
heal the pain but it is a much needed
distraction in the in trump thank you so
much tarika we appreciate you